bienvenidos acabamos de terminar este
problema con las poleas en un plano
inclinado y quisiera hacer una cosa más
antes de pasar a otro problema
interesante acabamos de encontrar que
todo este sistema se va a acelerar hacia
la derecha a 4.13 metros por segundo al
cuadrado y la segunda pregunta de
nuestro problema era cuál es la tensión
en esta cuerda o en este cable y ustedes
pueden pensar que esto es complicado ya
que todo está en movimiento y de hecho
se está acelerando así que cómo voy a
calcular la atención bueno en realidad
no es tan difícil lo que tenemos que
hacer es elegir una sección de este
sistema por ejemplo vamos a decir que
solo podemos ver esta masa de 20 kilos
es lo único que podemos ver de todo el
sistema sabemos que esta masa de 20
kilogramos está suspendida de un cable y
también sabemos que esta masa no se está
acelerando tanto como lo haría si no
estuviera sostenida por este cable
sabemos que ahorita está acelerando a 4
13 metros por segundo al cuadrado pero
si no tuviera este cable estaría
acelerando a 9.8 metros por segundo al
cuadrado que es la aceleración de la
gravedad por lo que este cable debe
estar ejerciendo una fuerza hacia arriba
para evitar esta aceleración completa y
esta fuerza hacia arriba es la fuerza de
tensión esto es lo que está moderando la
aceleración para que en lugar de que sea
9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado hacia
abajo sea solo de 4.13 metros por
segundo al cuadrado hacia abajo así que
nos interesa saber cuál es la fuerza
neta solamente en este objeto vamos a
ignorar esto que mencioné antes de la
fuerza neta en otros lugares y vamos a
concentrarnos en la fuerza neta en este
punto entonces la fuerza neta en este
punto o en este objeto es igual a la
masa del objeto que es de 20 kilogramos
multiplicado por la aceleración 4.13
metros por segundo al cuadrado y a
cuánto es igual esto
esto es igual aproximadamente a 83
newtons y su dirección es hacia abajo
esta fuerza de 83 newtons va hacia abajo
y también sabemos que la fuerza de
tensión más la fuerza de gravedad que la
fuerza de gravedad es el peso del objeto
la atención va hacia arriba la fuerza de
gravedad va hacia abajo es de 196 y todo
esto debe ser igual a estos 83 minutos
nuestra fuerza neta y yo sé que esta
fuerza de tensión es negativa
simplemente porque establece que todas
las fuerzas hacia abajo van a ser
positivas como esta y como esta ya que
va a ser igual mi tensión va a ser igual
a 83 menos 196 y esto nos da igual a
menos 113 newtons y de nuevo obtengo un
número negativo porque he usado el signo
positivo para
aquellas fuerzas que van hacia abajo y
esta va hacia arriba en sentido opuesto
así que esto es lo mismo que 113 newtons
hacia arriba y esta es mi tensión
y pudimos haber hecho exactamente lo
mismo en esta parte del sistema se
hubieran preguntado bueno cuál habría
sido la aceleración natural de este
objeto hacia acá de no haber existido
este cable que ejerce una fuerza hacia
acá y sabemos que de no ser por esta
fuerza que va hacia esta dirección este
peso seguiría con un cierta aceleración
así esta otra dirección entonces lo que
tendríamos que hacer es encontrar la
fuerza neta aquí y nuestra atención más
todas estas fuerzas que van hacia acá
deberían ser igual a nuestra fuerza neta
y sólo nos quedaría despejar la tensión
y encontrar su valor que debería ser
exactamente el mismo valor que
encontramos aquí ahora vamos a resolver
otro problema que es algo sencillo pero
también es bastante instructivo
aquí tengo un pastel aquí está una
charlita aquí está el relleno y aquí
está mi mano y aunque me gusta dibujar
las manos siempre me han costado mucho
trabajo de dibujar entonces aquí está mi
mano sosteniendo este pastel por aquí
sigue mi brazo más o menos y lo que
quiero hacer aunque no es algo muy
amable pero quiero darle un pastelazo en
la cara a esta persona
vamos a dibujar la de perfil
voy a tratar de dibujar lo mejor que
pueda y aunque me gusta dibujar pues
realmente a veces no es tan fácil hacer
las formas del cuerpo humano entonces
aquí está esta persona aquí está en sus
cejas su ojo
aquí están sonriendo porque pues no sabe
qué le voy a estampar este pastel en la
cara su oreja
a lo mejor tiene aquí su cabello
aquí un poco
quizás no tiene mucho cabello
no sé vamos a ponerle bigote y todas
ok
bueno aunque no debería estar enfocando
tanto en el dibujo sino en el problema
pero bueno ahí está entonces lo que
quiero hacer es lanzarle este pastel a
la cara a esta persona pero tengo que
encontrar cuál es la aceleración
necesaria para que este pastel no se me
caiga de las manos ya que en este pastel
está actuando la fuerza de gravedad y si
no tengo una aceleración lo
suficientemente rápida esta fuerza me va
a ganar y se me va a caer el pastel así
que como no quiero que esto se me caiga
tengo que saber qué tan rápido tengo que
mover el brazo para poder empujarlo aquí
y quizá ustedes no lo saben pero yo sí
lo sé que el coeficiente de fricción
entre mi mano y este pastel es de punto
8 mi coeficiente de fricción es punto 8
con este dato debo calcular qué tan
rápida es mi aceleración bueno esta es
la fuerza de gravedad y digamos que mi
pastel tiene una masa m m es igual a más
cuál será la fuerza de gravedad que está
actuando sobre este pastel pues la
fuerza de gravedad es igual a la masa
por 9.8 metros por segundo al cuadrado
que es la aceleración de la gravedad ok
esta es la fuerza de gravedad y que
sabemos de la fuerza neta que está
actuando sobre este pastel pues sabemos
que la fuerza neta actuando sobre este
pastel es igual a cero así que cuál será
mi fuerza compensatoria pues va a ser la
fuerza de fricción por lo que aquí tengo
en sentido contrario hacia arriba mi
fuerza de fricción porque la fuerza de
fricción siempre va a actuar en sentido
contrario del movimiento que tendría el
objeto por lo que mi fuerza de fricción
debe ser un poco mayor o mayor igual
tampoco puede ser demasiado grande
porque en lugar de moverse el país y
abajo se va a mover hacia arriba y eso
no ocurre una fuerza de fricción jamás
va a ser que se mueva algo simplemente
va a evitar que esa cosa se mueva en
otra
entonces bueno para evitar confusiones
vamos a decir que la fuerza de fricción
es igual
y 9.8 por la masa del pastel si el
coeficiente de fricción en 0.8 cuál va a
ser mi fuerza de fricción si mi
coeficiente de fricción es 0.8 cuál va a
ser la fuerza que tengo que aplicar en
esta dirección pues ésta va a ser la
fuerza normal la fuerza normal
perpendicular a la base de mi pastel así
que esta es mi fuerza normal bueno
sabemos que la fuerza de fricción es
igual al coeficiente de fricción por la
fuerza normal y sabemos que la fuerza de
fricción tiene que ser igual a 9.8 por m
por la masa entonces tenemos aquí 9.8
por m que esta es nuestra fuerza de
fricción igual a nuestro coeficiente de
fricción por la fuerza normal
y recuerden que la fuerza normal es la
fuerza con la que estoy lanzando el
pastel así que tenemos 9.8 por m pero
esta de més masa no son metros igual a
el coeficiente de fricción 0.8 por la
fuerza normal y nos interesa encontrar
la fuerza normal que es igual a 9.8 por
la masa entre 0.8 y cuánto va a ser esto
pues 9.8 entre punto 8 nos da
12.25 así que la fuerza que tengo que
aplicar es 12.25 multiplicado por la
masa de mi pastel lo dejo como m porque
no conozco cuál es la masa de este
pastel y cuál va a ser la aceleración de
este pastel bueno sabemos que la fuerza
es igual a la masa por la aceleración y
tenemos la fuerza
12.25
por m
es igual a la masa por la aceleración me
interesa la aceleración así que la
quiero despejar y está m es la misma
masa del pastel estas dos son las mismas
así que las podemos cancelar por lo que
mi aceleración o la tasa en la que tiene
que cambiar mi velocidad para que este
pastel no se me caiga de las manos y se
lo pueda aventar a la cara a esta
persona es de 12.25 metros por segundo
al cuadrado
así que tengo que aplicar más de una
gravedad como fuerza de aquí recordemos
que la gravedad acelera las cosas a 9.8
metros por segundo al cuadrado y aquí
tengo que usar 12.25 metros por segundo
al cuadrado
necesito acelerar a 12.25 metros por
segundo al cuadrado para tener esta
fuerza normal y mi fuerza normal genere
una fuerza de fricción suficiente para
que esto no se caiga y alcance mi
objetivo nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo